في البدايه من الفضاء فبعد قليل تنطلق
رحله جديده الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه
وعلمتها الرائد الاماراتي سلطان النيادي
النيادي سيمضي سته اشهر في الفضاء وقد
وصفت هذه المهمه بانها الاطول بالنسبه
للمنطقه العربيه الرحله ستتم على متن
صاروخ سبيس
والذي اكمل التحضيرات الانطلاق وبحسب
المعلومات المتوفره سيعمل سلطان ميادي على
تنفيذ 9/10 تجربه علميه على متن محطه
الفضاء الدوليه التعاون مع وكاله ناسا
وكاله فضائيه اخرى تشمل هذه التجارب
مجموعه من المجالات ابرزها نظام القلب
الاوعيه الدمويه وعلم ما فوق الجينات
ونتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره
لاستعدادات الانطلاق نحن نتحدث اليوم عن
اطول مهمه عربيه ستكون في الفضاء
وسيراسها الاماراتي النيادي الذي سيمضي
سته اشهر في الفضاء
سته اشهر وستخصص لاجراء التجارب العلميه
في الفضاء لمده سته اشهر في اطول رحله في
تاريخ المنطقه العربيه وطبعا نحن نتحدث عن
مهام عده ستجريها هذه البعثه لاستكشافيه
بالتعاون مع ناسا وايضا وكاله الفضاء
الاوروبيه ووكاله الفضاء الكنديه بالتاكيد
في خلال سياق حلقه صباح العربيه سنكون
معكم لنتابع صور مباشره
[موسيقى]